Prof: Okay,
so we're in the payoff period
of having spent all this time on
quantum mechanics,
and we want to see first
whether what we've done is
realistic or not.
So last time we looked at H-H
and H-F,
in terms of what the bond
strengths were,
and we saw that indeed one of
them was more stable for
breaking into ions and the other
more stable with respect to
breaking into atoms.
But here's a more extensive
reality check today,
which involves a lot more
experimental evidence.
And it has to do with XH_3;
that is, the molecules BH_3,
CH_3 and NH_3.
And we're going to look at
their structure,
and how they move,
and see how that checks out
with what we expect
theoretically.
So first, what do we expect
theoretically?
Well BH_3, CH_3_,
NH_3_ are the
same, except boron has three
valence electrons,
carbon has four,
and nitrogen has five.
Now each of them uses three of
their valence electrons to share
with hydrogens to make the three
XH_3 bonds.
But boron then has no leftover
electrons, carbon has one and
nitrogen has two.
So we want to see what the
implications of this are going
to be for the structure and
dynamic behavior of these
molecules,
and then we'll check it against
reality.
First we need to look at
something that shows that the
hybridization that you use to
make bonds should be related to
structure.
Now suppose there is one of
these atoms that uses an
sp hybrid orbital,
that looks like that.
You see the little dot where
the nucleus is.
And suppose it happens also to
use some other hybrid orbital to
make another bond.
Now, you want to have,
because of the Pauli Principle
--
and I'm sorry,
we don't have time to go into
this now --
the orbitals that you're using
must not overlap one another.
Because if there's net overlap
between two orbitals then --
and you have electrons in both
of them --
those electrons are,
to a certain extent,
the same thing,
if the orbitals overlap.
If they don't overlap,
then they're independent.
So to have only two electrons
per orbital, the orbitals must
not overlap.
So we can use that as a
criterion to say something about
what other orbitals could be
used at certain angles.
For example,
suppose the other hybrid
orbital that this atom was using
was sp^3.
Now you'll notice that --
remember -- let's suppose the
green and the blue are positive,
and the red and the yellow are
negative.
Now how much overlap is there?
Well there'll be positive
overlap where green overlaps
blue, and there'll be positive
overlap where red overlaps
yellow.
But there'll be negative
overlap where green overlaps
red, or where yellow overlaps --
no, where blue overlaps red,
or where green overlaps yellow.
Okay? Is that right?
Yeah, where blue overlaps red,
or green overlaps yellow;
that'll be negative.
And this, there'll be some
angle at which those things
exactly cancel out and you get
no net overlap,
no overlap integral.
And we're interested in knowing
what that angle would be;
that is, how should
hybridization be related to
angles, be related to structure?
Well, so the question is,
what's that angle?
And there's a nice formula,
that isn't too hard to work
out,
why it should be that way,
that relates sp^m and
sp^n,
the values m and
n, to the angle that
should be between them,
in order to have no overlap.
So let's use that formula and
look at several mn's,
and what the angles is.
Let's look at sp with
sp;
sp^2 with sp^2;
sp^3, sp^3;
and sp-anything with
sp^infinity.
What's sp^infinity?
That says the ratio of p
to s is infinite.
So it's a pure p.
So what angle would be pure
p orbital make with any
hybrid?
Okay, so those are the things
we're going to talk about.
So first let's try the first
one.
You can do the math for me.
Okay, so it's sp^1,
sp^1;
m and n are one.
So the denominator's the
√1,
that's one.
The cosine of the angle is
minus one.
What's the angle?
What angle has a cosine of
minus one?
Student:  180.
Prof: 180.
Okay, good.
So that would be linear.
And you knew that,
I bet, already.
Didn't they teach you that in
AP Chemistry,
that if you have two sp
orbitals,
they're linear,
or if you have bonds that point
opposite direction you use
sp hybrids for them.
If they didn't,
that's true anyhow.
Okay?
Now how about sp^2,
sp^2?
So we're going to have m
and n are both two;
√4 is two.
So it's the angle whose cosine
is minus one half.
Anybody know what that is?
I don't -- pardon me?
Sixty?
That's +½.
It's 120, to be -½;
it has to be greater than
ninety to be negative.
So that's going to be
120º, and that's trigonal.
So sp^2 hybrids make an
angle of 120º.
Now how about sp^3
hybrids?
That's √9;
so minus a third.
That one probably isn't stored
in your head,
but it's an interesting angle.
It's 109.5º,
which is the angle in a
tetrahedron.
Right?
So that methane,
which makes sp^3 bonds
at the carbon,
has tetrahedral angles,
109.5º.
Now, how about
sp-anything,
with n=infinity?
What's the denominator?
Students:  Infinity.
Prof: It's infinity.
So what's the angle whose
cosine is…
Student:  90º
Prof: Okay,
90º.
Right?
So that means -- that is what
makes things σ and
π.
Right?
A p orbital,
with any other hybrid,
has to be perpendicular to it.
So you won't -- that's what we
talked about,
σ and π,
last time.
So the p orbital is
π, and it's
perpendicular to anything else,
90º, no matter what other
hybrid.
Okay, so now how about this
particular one we have here
where it's sp^3 and
sp^1?
That turns out to 125.3º.
So that's what the angle should
be, if the carbon were making
one bond with sp and one
with sp^3.
Right?
But the important thing here is
that's there's a relationship
between hybridization of two
orbitals on the same atom and
what the angle should be between
them.
Yes, Angela?
Student:  When would you
have an sp^3 and an
sp hybrid;
like be at angles?
Prof: Well we're going
to have to decide what
determines the hybridization.
Right?
And it could be different for
two bonds from the same atom,
and we'll see examples of that.
So that will become answered
soon.
It's if they're bonding to
different kinds of things,
they may have different
hybridizations;
and we'll see an example of
that, several examples.
So we want to optimize the
hybridization,
that is to get -- yes,
Lucas?
Student:  Does different
weightings of the hybridized
orbitals change the angle,
degrees?
Prof: Yes,
there are two ways.
You could change the angle by
moving the nuclei around,
for some other reason,
whatever it is,
and that would then change the
hybridization of the carbon
that's making the bonds.
So it works both ways.
If you change the
hybridization,
you change the angle;
if you change the angle,
you change the hybridization.
Okay, now we want to optimize
hybridization.
What do mean, optimize?
We mean we want to get the
lowest possible energy.
We want to choose the
hybridization that'll give the
lowest hybridization ,
and therefore a particular
geometry, for XH^3,
certain angles.
Okay, now let's think about
that.
We're going to have one of the
valence electrons of the X atom
in each of three bonding atomic
orbitals,
bonding to the hydrogen,
and whatever's left over goes
into the fourth atomic orbital,
and we want to minimize the
energy.
Okay?
Now let's first look at it from
the point of view of the bonds.
We want to make the strongest
possible bonds.
We want to maximize the overlap
in the bonds.
What hybrid gives the best
overlap?
sp.
But we have to make three bonds;
sp you can only make two
bonds.
So what's the best you can use
if you want to make three bonds?
Student:  sp^2.
Prof: sp^2^(.
)So no matter whether it's
BH_3, CH_3_ or NH_3,
all of them will overlap best
in making three bonds,
if you use sp^2_.
So the bonds cry out,
"Use sp^2";
that'll maximize the overlap
and minimize the energy of the
electrons in the bonds.
Okay?
But that's not the only game in
town, because there's also the
other electron that's on the
atom, if there is another
electron.
Okay?
Because carbon has one and
nitrogen has two other
electrons.
So they should get a say in it
too.
So the X atom,
which has to accommodate
whatever's left over,
says, "Okay, go ahead,
make three bonds,
but get the lowest energy for
the other electron,
that I'm the only one
responsible for."
Right?
So what's the lowest energy you
could make for a pair of
electrons, or for a single
electron;
what's the lowest energy
valence orbital?
Students:  s.
Prof: s.
So the atom says,
"Okay, make your three
bonds, but make sure you don't
let s orbital go
begging."
Right?
Use the maximum you can of s
orbital, because otherwise
you're using high-energy atomic
orbitals when you might not need
to.
Now sometimes these would agree
and sometimes they would fight
with one another,
the bonds and the atom.
Okay?
So from the point of view of
the atom, boron,
with only three valence
electrons, all being used in
bonds, doesn't have anything
else.
So it would certainly want to
use three sp^2 and leave
the p orbital vacant.
That gets the maximum utility
out of the s;
puts the s where the
electrons are.
So that's what boron says,
use three sp^2's,
for the bonds.
What does carbon say -- no,
pardon me, what does nitrogen
say?
Nitrogen, if it wanted to be
the best atom,
would put two electrons,
the unshared pair,
into the s orbital,
and one into each of the
remaining three p
orbitals.
Right?
That gets the maximum use of
out of s.
You don't want to waste s
by putting it where there's
only one electron on the
nitrogen atom.
You want to use it where there
are two electrons.
Okay, so nitrogen says,
"Well,
I'd prefer to use three p
orbitals to make my bonds,
and put two electrons into the
s orbital."
Okay?
Now, what does carbon say?
Carbon says,
"Look, I got four
electrons;
three of them are going to be
in some kind of hybrid,
that's going to make the bonds,
and one of them's going to be
something else.
But if I take the s out
of one place,
I'm going to put it into the
other one.
Over all the four,
I'm going to use up all the
s character.
There's one electron in each of
them.
Who cares?" Right?
So carbon really doesn't care,
from the point of view of the
carbon atom, about
hybridization.
It'll care for making -- for
the bonds, but it doesn't care
for the unshared electron.
Okay, but now we have to
reconcile these two
considerations.
So the boron will make the best
bonds if it uses sp^2 and
it'll make the best atom if it
uses sp^2.
So great, they agree.
So boron should really want to
use sp^2 hybrids for its
bonds.
Remember, those are the ones
that form 120º.
So it'll be the pattern of a
Mercedes star.
Yes, Yoonjoo?
Student:  Can you
explain again why we use three
p instead of like,
the hybrid orbitals for
nitrogen?
Prof: If you're just
looking at a nitrogen atom,
it's going to have two
electrons in one of its
orbitals,
and one in each of three other
orbitals.
Right?
So those two electrons,
that orbital that holds two
electrons, should be as low as
possible in energy;
and that's s.
So put two in s and one in each
of the three p's,
and that'll give the lowest
energy atom,
with one electron in each of
the four orbitals --
pardon me, with two in one and
three in the other three;
one in each of the other three.
Okay?
Okay, so but anyhow,
with BH_3_ they
agree, from both points of view:
the strongest bonds and the
best atom.
So it'll certainly want to be
flat, and 120º
bond angles.
Now how about CH_3?
CH_3, from the point of view of
the bonds, wants to be
sp^2, and the atom
doesn't care.
So fine, be sp^2,
be flat, be planar,
with 120º
bond angles.
But it won't care quite as much
as boron does.
So carbon says it'll prefer to
be planar, but not as strongly;
so it'll be easier to bend it,
because it doesn't have this
consideration of leaving a p
orbital vacant.
Okay?
And now about nitrogen?
Now you got a fight on your
hands -- right?
-- because the bonds want to be
flat and 120º
bond angles,
but the atom wants to use
p orbitals,
90º angles for the bonds;
so like the corner of a cube
would be the nitrogen,
the bonds would be going out at
90º angles.
So here there's going to have
to be some compromise.
Okay?
So NH_3, since it must
compromise, won't be either
perfectly flat or 90º
angles, but something in
between.
It'll be pyramidal.
Okay?
Now are the predictions clear;
and the reason for them?
Yoonjoo, do you see now,
why it's the way it is?
Don't let me bully you into it,
if you don't really understand.
Dana?
Student:  Can you
explain the difference in what
the atoms and the bonds want for
nitrogen again?
Prof: Yes,
what we want to do is get the
lowest possible energy.
The lowest energy for the bonds
will be the best overlap.
You're making three bonds.
So sp^2 will give the
lowest energy,
as far as the bonds go.
But there also might be -- and
that's the only game in town for
boron.
Right?
But in carbon you have another
electron you have to
accommodate,
and there's a question of what
energy it will have,
even though it's not being
shared.
And in nitrogen there are two
of those other electrons.
Now, the best orbital of an
atom, for an electron to be in,
the lowest energy,
is s.
And in nitrogen there are going
to be two electrons that want to
be in an s orbital.
If they do that,
they use up the s
orbital, and the only thing
you have left over to make the
bonds is the p orbital.
So now you've got a fight on
your hands.
Are you going to have sharp
angles and have the unshared
pair in a low-energy,
s orbital but weak
bonds, or are you going to have
strong bonds,
sp^2,
but put the unpaired electrons
in a p orbital?
Okay, Kevin,
did you have a question or did
that answer it?
Okay.
Yes?
I can't hear very well.
Student:  Is there such
a thing as an sp^3
orbital?
Prof: Yes.
What does sp^3^( )mean?
It means a hybrid orbital,
a mixture of s and
p, with three times as
much p as s.
Okay?
You could have that.
You could have three
sp^3 bonds,
for nitrogen,
for example,
and then an sp^3 hybrid,
in which the unshared pair
lives.
Okay?
That would be a possibility,
sure.
And that's the kind of thing
I'm talking about here,
by saying it would be
intermediate,
between being 90º
bond angles and 120º
bond angles,
flat.
Any more questions?
Yes?
Student:  Why are we
concerned about the atomic
orbitals rather than molecular
orbitals?
Prof: Ah,
I'm going to get to that just
shortly here.
So, because we're talking about
bonds.
Bonds are local.
Bonds don't go over the whole
molecule.
Molecular orbitals go over the
whole molecule.
And we've been talking thus
far, mostly,
in terms of molecular orbitals,
but now we're shifting to talk
about bonds,
because what we wanted to do
was talk about bonds.
And I'll do a little about the
philosophy of that shortly.
Okay?
So here are the predictions.
BH_3 should strongly want to be
planar and be hard to bend.
CH_3 should want to be planar
but be easy to bend.
And NH_3_ should be
easy to distort out of plane,
so that it's not flat;
in fact, not only should it be
easy to distort,
it should prefer to distort in
its lowest energy form.
Okay, so now let's see if
that's true.
Is it true that that unshared
pair will compete for s
character, and therefore make
nitrogen pyramidal?
Now, how do we know?
There's our prediction:
distortion from the plane will
weaken the bond and deprive the
electrons of s character;
so it doesn't want to bend.
Here, distortion from the plane
weakens the bonds,
but it shifts s
character to the lone electron,
where at least it's not wasted,
because there is at least an
electron there.
And in NH_3,
it weakens the bonds but it
shifts s character from
single electrons to a pair of
electrons;
which is something good.
Okay, so are these predictions
true?
Well, we need experiment.
How about X-ray for seeing the
structure of BH_3,
CH_3, NH_3?
How about NH_3?
Have you ever seen NH_3?
Have you ever smelled NH_3?
It's ammonia.
So how about doing X-ray on it?
Student:  No.
Prof: Why not? Shai?
Student:  Because you
can only use X-ray to see
electrons --
Prof: Can't hear very
well.
Student:  You can only
use X-ray to see electrons;
those are the ones that are
going to move when you ---
Prof: No,
that's not the main problem.
Yes?
Student:  You can't make
it a crystal.
Prof: You have to have a
crystal to do X-ray
crystallography,
and NH_3 is a gas.
Now you might say,
okay, we'll cool it way down to
liquid nitrogen temperature and
then maybe it'll crystallize.
It'll be difficult to grow a
crystal of ammonia,
but it's conceivable we might
be able to grow a crystal of
ammonia.
Okay?
Can we use the same trick for
CH_3 and BH_3?
That one's a gas.
Okay?
CH_3, unfortunately,
if you get two of them together
they react, to get C_2H_6.
So you're never going to be
able to cool them down and get a
crystal.
And the same thing is true of
BH_3.
It forms B_2H_6.
Right?
So forget crystals for this.
We can't use X-ray
crystallography,
the technique we've used so far
to do this.
But there are other techniques
for finding structure,
and the one we're going to talk
about --
actually we're going to talk
about two --
but we're going to talk about,
not X-ray,
we're going to talk about IR --
we're going to talk about
spectroscopy,
infrared spectroscopy,
and electron spin resonance
spectroscopy.
Okay?
We're going to talk more about
infrared spectroscopy next
semester,
but I'll show you just enough
to get through the question that
we're interested in now;
Does that remind you of
anything that moves like in a
high wind?
Student: A weathervane.
Prof: It's like an
umbrella, right?
In a high wind it blows inside
out.
Okay, so this is sometimes
called the "umbrella"
vibration of XH_3.
And you can treat it with
Erwin Meets Goldilocks,
as if it's one-dimension;
just how much motion of all
these atoms, how much motion.
You know what the masses of the
atoms are.
You know the kind of motion
you're interested in.
It's all coordinated.
So you're changing really just
one-dimension,
in moving all these things in a
coordinated way back and forth.
Right?
So you can treat it as an Erwin
problem, with a fictitious mass
that reflects the amount of
motion of each of the four
atoms, while that's happening.
Okay, so here's BH_3 doing that
out-of-plane-bending vibration,
the umbrella vibration,
and CH_3 doing the same thing
with its electron.
Now, it turns out that BH_3
vibrates 34-trillion times a
second.
Okay?
And that's called 34.2
terahertz;
that's how often it vibrates.
CH_3 vibrates 18.7 terahertz;
so only half as fast as BH_3.
Does this make sense?
Suppose the springs that you're
bending when you do this
vibration -- suppose it's
springs -- which set of springs
is stiffer?
The BH_3 or the -- does a stiff
spring make a vibration faster
or slower?
Student:  Faster.
Prof: Faster.
So it says the springs are
stiffer in BH_3.
It prefers to be planar more
strongly than CH_3 does.
Right?
Now, you might ask -- what
might you ask at this stage,
when I tell you that it
vibrates that fast?
<<Students speak over one
another>>
Prof: No,
that's not the question I want.
Student:  How can you
tell?
Prof: How do you know?
How do I know that it vibrates
at that frequency?
Well, so it would be a stiffer
spring, but how do I know?
Well, when it vibrates,
the electric charge is moving
back and forth.
Right?
So the direction of the --
there's a dipole there,
+/-, and it's moving back and
forth.
And what does that create,
when you have charges moving
back and forth?
Electromagnetic radiation.
Right?
So electromagnetic radiation is
going to come out,
as this thing vibrates,
like that.
And it comes out with a shorter
wavelength for BH_3 than for
CH_3.
Right?
And it turns out that the
wavelength is such that for BH_3
there are 1100 vibrations,
waves, in a centimeter;
short wavelengths.
And it's longer wavelengths,
only 600 waves in a centimeter
for CH_3.
Now, we can also -- so
different light would come out,
infrared light,
of these two;
or different colors of light,
infrared light,
get absorbed.
That's how you actually measure
it.
And remember,
the frequency of light has to
do with the energies of the
photon.
So in, if you take the quantum
mechanical view that you go from
one quantized state to another
quantized state,
when you absorb,
or emit, light,
then we know,
from this frequency,
that in one case the two energy
levels you're talking about are
separated by 3.26 kcal/mole,
and in the other case by 1.73
kcal/mole;
only about half as much.
Is everybody on board with this
so far?
So it's from the absorption of
infrared light that we know how
fast they vibrate,
and therefore how stiff the
springs are.
Okay?
Now just how stiff are they?
Well we can use Erwin for this
point of view.
We have the amount of
deformation, which is our
one-dimension,
as it goes back and forth,
and we can assume that it's
something like Hooke's Law --
that's an assumption -- the
distortion,
these springs.
And then we can adjust the
potential, how sharp the
parabola is, of potential
energy, until we get two
energies that are spaced like
that.
Does everybody see what we're
doing?
So here we do it.
On the left,
we get these lowest two energy
levels and we -- there's the
parabola that does the trick.
So that's a strong,
a stiff spring,
strong planar preference.
And in the case of CH_3,
to get that lower energy
separation, you need a broader
parabola.
It's easier to bend;
the springs are softer.
Okay?
Everybody see how that worked?
Okay, so infrared spectroscopy
then tells us that first,
that it prefers to be planar,
and second, that it's stiffer
for boron than it is for carbon;
just as we predicted.
Okay?
Now how about for NH_3?
For NH_3, you see two
absorptions in the infrared,
and they're very near one
another;
968 and 932 wavenumbers;
that is, waves per centimeter.
If we translate that,
it means that there are two
energy levels --
there's a low energy level --
and then there are two that are
very close to one another,
in order to have these two
different colors of infrared
light being absorbed.
How can we get this?
How can we get -- this is not
Hooke's Law.
Remember what happens with
Hooke's Law in the energy
spacing?
What happens?
They're even.
Remember?
So this isn't anything like
Hooke's Law.
Where do you get two that are
very similar to one another?
Do you remember?
Students:
Double minimum.
Prof: What?
Students:
Double minimum.
Prof: A double minimum
gives that.
So NH_3_ must be a
double minimum,
like this.
Right?
And those must -- the blue and
the red one, must be the one
with three nodes and the one
with two nodes.
There's also one with zero
nodes, and one with one node.
But those are both down at the
bottom.
Right?
They have the same energy,
because there's not enough
overlap between the two to make
them split.
Right?
So the IR spectroscopy of
ammonia tells you it's a double
minimum, and also,
in order to get that spacing,
tells you how big the barrier
is.
It costs three kcal/mole to
make NH_3 planar.
It prefers to be pyramidal.
Okay?
And that splitting,
that "tunnel"
splitting,
that we talked about before,
for those two levels,
is thirty-seven wavenumbers.
Remember, there's also the two
that are down at the bottom,
with zero and one node,
and they're separated by only
one wavenumber;
they're very close to one
another.
But we can translate that into
the tunneling frequency,
when you're down in the lowest
energy levels.
How fast does it go back and
forth?
And you remember how to do that.
If one wavenumber is two small
calories/mole,
not kilocalories,
and we use that thing that we
talked about in lecture nine,
about how to go from splitting
to tunneling rate;
and it turns out that in the
ground state,
in the lowest energy state,
ammonia is flipping back and
forth 10^11 times a second.
And in fact for a while that
was used as a fundamental clock;
here was something that you
really knew the frequency of.
Hooke, when he was trying to
devise a clock that could tell
where you were in longitude,
could've used ammonia,
if he'd had the technology to
do it,
which would be an absolute
frequency.
Okay, so IR shows -- completely
confirms what we said before,
that BH_3_ is stiff
and flat;
CH_3 is easily bent and flat;
and NH_3 is not bent,
but can tunnel back and forth,
by the umbrella motion.
Okay, so now the other
technique I want to tell you
about is electron spin resonance
spectroscopy.
And it turns out -- and we
don't have time to go into this
--
well you know already that
electrons are magnetic,
and some nuclei are magnetic,
and you can get a magnetic
interaction between the nucleus
and the electron,
which influences how hard it is
to change the electron from
being pointing one way to being
pointing another way.
That's a kind of spectroscopy;
see what color of light you
need to make an electron flip
from being pointed one way to
the other way.
But it's influenced by the
magnet, which is the nucleus.
But there's a neat thing about
it, which is that influence can
occur only when the electron is
inside the nucleus.
Where, in a 1s orbital,
is the highest electron
density?
Remember the formula for a
1s electron?
What's the atomic orbital?
It's a constant times what?
Prof: e^-ρ.
Where's it biggest?
Student:  At zero.
Prof: Inside the nucleus
is the most dense part of the
electron.
Right?
So when the electron is inside
the nucleus it feels this
effect.
When it's not inside the
nucleus it does not feel the
effect, for the purpose of this
spectroscopy.
Okay?
So we can measure how much
s character there is in a
hybrid orbital that holds an
electron by seeing how strongly
the nucleus interacts with the
electron;
because it happens only to the
extent that it's s.
Right?
So we could measure the percent
of s character by
measuring the light that's
absorbed by the electron.
Christopher?
Student:  How could the
electron ever actually be inside
the nucleus?
Wouldn't that have two
particles occupying the same
space?
Prof: But they're
different particles.
And in fact it's a little more
complicated than that,
because what's the kinetic
energy, if the distance is zero?
Coulombic energy is 1/r.
Suppose r is zero.
What's the kinetic energy?
Student: It's infinite.
Prof: Infinite. Right?
Now, that means the electron is
really zinging,
which means it becomes
relativistic and its mass
changes and all sorts of wild
things occur.
So it's actually that which
causes this interaction.
So we'll leave that across the
way here in Sloane Physics Lab.
Okay?
And take it from me,
that the amount of this
splitting that you see in the
ESR spectrum depends on how much
s character there is on
the orbital.
Okay?
And you can worry about whether
it's precisely inside the
nucleus, or just so heavy and
fast that it's behaving weirdly.
Okay?
But anyhow, that's the trick.
Okay, so the singly-occupied
molecular orbital,
the one where there's only one
electron,
in CH_3, will give rise to
electron spin resonance,
and the magnitude of this
effect will tell you how much
s orbital there is.
Okay, so let's look at it.
And this is what I just said.
There's a line separation due
to magnetic interaction,
and it occurs only if the
electron spends time on the
nucleus,
which happens only for an
s orbital;
so we can measure how much
s orbital.
Okay, so here's a picture of
planar CH_3, and the orbital,
the singly occupied molecular
orbital, SOMO,
that contains the electron.
How much time is it spending on
the nucleus?
Zero;
there's a node at the nucleus,
it's in a p orbital.
Now suppose we bend it,
so it looks like that;
or we could look inside and it
looks like that.
Now it's got some s
character, in that orbital.
Right?
And if we make little boxes and
blow them up to see what it
looks like down near the
nucleus,
one of them has no density at
the nucleus and the other has
electron density at the nucleus.
So you'll see magnetic
interaction, in this case.
If it's bent you'll see
magnetic interaction,
and the more bent,
the smaller that angle from 120
--
remember, the smaller the
angle, so it'll go down toward
ninety;
the more s character,
there'll be more of it.
Okay, so here's what you see
for CH_3.
Bear in mind it has to be
magnetic C, it has to be C-13^(
)H_3, not C-12,
in order to see the spitting.
But at any rate,
the amount of this effect is
thirty-eight gauss,
which are the units it can be
measured in.
And that implies that,
on average, it's 2% s.
Now, remember we already said
that its lowest energy form is
flat, with no s.
But it's constantly undergoing
this umbrella vibration.
So it's spending time with
different amounts of s
character, not zero,
as it vibrates.
And the average is 2%.
Now suppose I made the
hydrogens heavier,
by making them deuterium.
So I make the atoms heavier.
Do you remember how that
changes the shape of the
wavefunction,
if I make things heavier?
Here it is for H is moving.
What if it were deuteriums that
are moving, how will the thing
change?
Student:
>
Prof: It'll get narrower.
So as it gets narrower,
that means it's not bending as
much, on average.
And what should happen to the
thirty-eight gauss,
if it doesn't bend as much?
Student:
>
Prof: I'll let you think
about it a second.
It's only when it's bent that
it has s character and
you see this effect.
If it were rigidly flat,
the splitting would be zero;
thirty-eight would be zero.
What would happen if I change H
to D, so that it doesn't bend as
much, on average?
Sophie, what would you say?
Student:
[inaudible>>
Prof: Can't hear.
Student:  If it was more
rigid it would --
Prof: If it were more
rigid it would -- how big would
the effect be?
Bigger or smaller, the gauss?
Student:  Smaller.
Prof: Pardon me?
Prof: Thirty-six. Right?
So again it confirms what we're
saying, that it prefers to be
flat.
It's only when it bends that
you get this effect,
and it bends less with heavier
atoms than with lighter atoms.
Wonderful.
So again it confirms what we
said.
There's what CD_3_
looks like.
It's a little bit narrower and
therefore a little bit less of
this magnetic interaction.
So this is a structural isotope
effect.
CH_3 spends more time more bent
than CD_3, and thus uses more
s character,
and thus gives a bigger
magnetic interaction.
Okay, so again we've confirmed
what we predicted.
Now here's one that we didn't
work on in predicting,
is CF_3.
Now what's changing H to F
going to do?
Well, it's going to be heavier.
So the same deal that would
happen with deuterium should
happen here.
But there might be more to it
than that, because now we have
more protons and a bigger
nuclear charge of the atoms that
were H before.
So they're going to attract the
electrons in the bond more.
So, but there's another thing
too.
Because the fluorines have a
partial negative charge,
and are bigger,
they have more electrons
altogether, they'll repel one
another.
Now what would -- if the things
attached to the central carbon
get bigger and repel one
another, what effect should that
have on it being bent?
Should it make it easier or
harder to bend?
Student:  Harder.
Prof: If these things
are big here?
Easier to bend from flat,
or harder, if these things are
--
Students:  Harder.
Prof: Harder, right?
So valence electron pair
repulsion, and all that,
should say that if CH_3 is
flat, what about CF_3?
Student:  It's flatter.
Prof: It should really
be flat, harder to bend,
if these things are bigger.
Okay.
But there's another point of
view that you can take,
which is that fluorine has the
lion's share of the bonding
electron pair.
The bonding electron pair,
in each of the C-F bonds,
is spending more time near
fluorine than near carbon.
So carbon, being a cagy sort of
character,
says, "Why should I waste
my valuable s character
trying to stabilize these
electrons that are spending
their time on fluorine
anyway?"
Right?
"Why don't I use it to
stabilize that other electron,
that's only on me and not on
fluorine?"
Got the idea?
So if carbon uses its s
character to go to the odd
electron,
forgetting the ones that are
mostly on fluorine anyway,
then that would make it more
bent.
That would favor bending,
if you put the s
character in the odd electron
rather than in the bonds.
That'll favor using more
p character in the bonds
and therefore more bending.
So this is exactly the kind of
thing that Bacon would have
liked.
Right?
This is a crucial experiment.
There are two opposite
predictions, and you can do an
experiment and find out which
one is true.
Is it that fluorine is bigger
and negatively charged,
so it makes it more flat?
Or is it that the carbon says,
"I want to put my
electron,
the only electron I'm really
solely responsible for,
in the orbital with the most
s?"
Right?
So this is a real horserace and
you place your bets.
Okay?
Now how many people think it's
-- we'll guess ahead of time --
how many people think that
fluorines are bigger and
negatively charged,
so it will be harder to bend
away from planarity?
And how many people think that
it's the odd electron,
that you want to put s
character in?
Well this is very close.
Okay?
So we'll have to look at
experiment.
Okay, so this is the
singly-occupied molecular
orbital of CF_3.
It's mostly on the central
carbon, but a little bit on the
fluorines.
And if you look in the middle,
you see that there's the
s character on the
carbon.
And if we measure the
splitting, it's 271 gauss.
What was it for methane?
Students:  Thirty-eight.
Prof: Thirty-eight.
This is ten times almost,
or whatever number of times,
maybe like eight times more
s character than there
was in methane.
What's the conclusion?
It's much more bent,
much more of the time,
than CH_3_ is.
Right?
Okay, so that means it's 20%
s.
That means that it's
sp^4 in that,
almost sp^3.
Right?
So it's almost perfectly
pyramidal, like methane would
be.
Right?
So it's the character of that
odd electron,
wanting to be s,
that's controlling the
geometry.
Okay, now we're going to get to
what Christopher wanted,
which is why the heck are we
talking about bonds when we've
been talking about molecular
orbitals all the time?
Well one reason is we
wanted to talk about
bonds.
That's how we got into this
whole thing, asking what bonds
are.
Okay?
But there are three different
operators here,
and they have different
motivation and methods.
First there's the molecule
deciding what to be;
and then there's the computer
doing quantum mechanics,
deciding what the molecule
should do;
and then there's you,
trying to understand all this.
And these are different.
And let's see the way in which
they're different.
The experimental molecule,
all it wants to know --
it doesn't care about
Schrödinger --
all it wants to do is get the
lowest possible energy.
So it minimized the total
energy, kinetic plus Coulomb
energies,
of the electrons and the
nuclei, by just settling down
into the most comfortable,
lowest energy arrangement.
Okay?
That's what the molecule does,
it just gets happy.
Okay?
And once it does that,
then it has a certain
structure, a certain arrangement
of the nuclei and of the
electron clouds.
It has a total electron
density, which you can measure
by X-ray.
It has certain energies that we
showed measuring by IR;
although you can measure them
other ways as well.
It has nuclear electron
density, that we just measured
by ESR.
It has dipole moment,
how much there's a separation
of positive and negative,
that you can -- that if it
vibrates gives off IR and so on.
So there are these real things
that come from the molecule just
doing what comes naturally.
So it doesn't care about
Schrödinger.
Now you have a computer that
comes along,
armed with Schrödinger's
equation,
and it knows it can't possibly
solve the true Schrödinger
equation,
it's too complicated.
So it'll do some approximation
and try to get an approximate
value.
So it'll minimize the total
energy, using the
Schrödinger equation,
with some realistic
constraints;
for example,
using orbitals,
or using configuration
interaction, or using density
functional theory,
or some approximation.
Okay?
So it'll use like a limited set
of atomic orbitals,
only say 2s and -- it
won't use the 5p orbital
or the 5g orbital or
something like that.
Use Self-Consistent Field,
or some correlation,
or delocalized molecular
orbitals come out.
And its goal is to get a useful
prediction of the properties;
maybe the electron density,
maybe the energy,
maybe the vibration frequency,
maybe absorption of,
what colors of light get
absorbed and so on.
So the goal of the computer is
to use any tricks it can get
around --
it can do, and it doesn't care
how hard it works --
it's not something you have to
be able to do on a piece of
paper --
just to get something useful.
And it will be validated,
the approximations you made,
by experiment.
If it agrees with experiment,
then you can believe the
computer.
But that doesn't mean you
understand what the computer
did.
Right?
It's a really complicated
calculation.
And that's different from what
you want to do,
because your goal is to
understand structure and
reactivity, with the simplest
realistic model;
not Schrödinger's
fundamental equation,
because you don't have the
brain power to manipulate
numbers that way and do all
these integrals and so on;
leave that to the computer.
Your goal is to try to look at
things and understand:
ah!
that should be reactive with
this;
that bond should be very stiff;
that molecular structure should
be very stiff because the,
quote, "bonds"
should be stiff.
Okay?
That's what you want to do is
to develop an intuition that
allows you to understand
structure and reactivity.
And you want the simplest,
obviously, but realistic model.
And that, to be both simple and
realistic, may not be possible.
Right?
There's a certain tension there.
Okay?
So what kind of things you'll
talk about?
You'll talk about localized
bonds.
You won't talk about these big
things that are complicated and
go over the whole molecule.
It's interesting to see,
for example,
that those are analogous to
atomic orbitals and that kinetic
energy plays a part in them,
but that doesn't empower you to
predict the properties of
things.
Okay?
So you want to talk about
localized bonds,
maybe pretend they're springs
or something like that.
And what makes a spring stiff
or not stiff?
And that, Christopher,
is why we have been talking
about springs and things here,
rather than talking about
molecular orbitals.
So you talk about -- these are
Lewis's ideas -- bonds,
lone-pairs, hybridization.
We talk about energy-match and
overlap.
And we'll be talking soon about
HOMOs and LUMOs --
highest occupied molecular
orbital,
lowest unoccupied molecular
orbital --
and what a very important thing
those are.
So we're going to look at just
little bits of things,
to try to find out what's
crucial and will allow us to
understand.
We want them to be realistic.
We want them fundamentally to
be based on something true,
like quantum mechanics,
not just on springs.
But we have to make it simple
enough to understand.
So we're aiming for qualitative
insight.
And we'll know when we're right
if we agree with experiment,
and also if we agree with what
the computer predicts;
even though the computer
doesn't know why it predicted
it, it just grinds through and
gets you a number.
But we want to understand why
the computer gets that number.
Okay.
So let me just do one thing
quickly here.
Pathological Bonding.
Or let me let you go to your
next class;
we'll do Pathological Bonding
next time.